and now you have this young girl who is
eloquently reading our leftist globalist
platitudes about you know religions of
peace and all the rest of it and winning
the hearts of millions you know ball
along and against that you've got all
the actual facts you know like dead
people and all the Middle East stuff if
all of this and the obvious confection
that is Malala
she's obviously like a little media
product if none of that works what's
going to work or are we are we stuffed
well of course it's gonna work for a lot
of people no matter what we do but if I
were on a stage debating Malala which of
course would never happen because her
handlers would never allow it but I'm
willing Malala if you are challenged in
Malala yousufzai you just be
characterized as a bully yes of course
because she's just a little girl who got
shot got shot no no she's a Muslim she's
a woman and she got shot right after
these three reasons nothing comes out of
her mouth except pearls of wisdom as
quote the people who she's funding
she's funding groups in Gaza she's
funding schools in Gaza and that
wonderful and in the schools they're
taught killing Jews as our active
worship that's pleasing to Allah yes and
I would start to to just quote all that
and say this is what your money is going
for if you give to Malala
[Music]
constant fact of life being conservative
in America today is being shut down
having your avenues of revenue squeezed
and throttled from you being suffocated
being banned and excise from public life
this is something we are all
experiencing supporters if you can
you'll be able to enjoy an hour or so of
me every day Monday to Friday we'll be
in the studio entertaining and amusing
you will have serious substantive
interviews several days of the week if
you want to enjoy this show please go to
dangerous calm slash join